[Aplausos]
una marcha en rechazo a lo ocurrido en
la ileus a la que asistieron ciudadanos
y funcionarios electos a la cabeza de la
marcha
alcalde de la ciudad aplaudido por sus
electores una muestra de solidaridad
después de que su casa fuera embestida
el sábado por la noche con un coche su
esposa y sus hijos pequeños fueron
atacados con fuegos artificiales y
resultaron heridos mientras intentaban
escapar
no se imaginan Hasta qué punto su
presencia aquí es un poderoso mensaje
tan necesario tras seis noches de
disturbios y saqueos en todo el país
desencadenados por el tiroteo mortal de
la policía contra un adolescente de
ascendencia Nora africana para muchos se
cruzó una nueva línea Roja en este
ataque personal
lo ocurrido es atroz incomprensible
atacar su casa y a sus hijos estarán
traumatizados por esto durante años por
eso estoy aquí
alcaldes y vecinos se reunieron en
decenas de ayuntamientos de todo el país
desde tu luz hasta can y París
es importante que el país reaccione que
digamos que no que digamos pasta que
haya una protesta generalizada y solemne
hemos condenado sin reservas la
violencia y los ataques contra bienes y
personas aquí nadie puede justificar la
violencia
unos 99 ayuntamientos han sido atacados
al igual que cientos de edificios
públicos